if men and women are not different if  they're the same if they're identical  then what is a woman why do we have a  different word to describe things that  are exactly the same if men and women  are exactly the same then why do we need  feminism wouldn't we just need humanism  or something a humanitarianism manism  why would we have two separate terms for  this what feminism does in so much as  modern feminism denies the categories of  gender refuses to put a box around  gender and say in order to be a woman  you need a uterus and X chromosomes and  this or that or the other thing by  denying those categories they destroy  the concept of Womanhood itself